[Music]
my name is steve winter and i've been a
contributing photographer with national
geographic for over 20 years wired has
challenged me to take what i have
learned about photographing big cats in
the wild to photographing a domestic cat
today i'm going to show you my process
for going from 112 photos
down to only one
for my first edit i'm gonna edit for
technical issues whether it's too dark
too light things like that so here we go
it just happens to be photo number one
this image is underexposed bye-bye
one thing you have to look for when
you're depending on the exposure in the
background that a big cloud doesn't come
over and all of a sudden you're two to
three stops off so let's see what would
the next one be this one here is a
little under i kind of like the movement
in it but it's underexposed light didn't
go off underexposed underexposed under
exposure on the cat's face underexposed
another underexposure underexposed
underexposed if we're coming on a
situation in the field as we're speeding
up to that location i will just take a
out of focus shot just to check it i'll
set the camera the way i think it should
be and then i'll do a test shot and
adjust accordingly this one is
overexposed
no good and overexposed overexposed and
overexposure overexposed overexposure in
the bottom overexposed overexposed
that concludes the first edit
all right in the second edit we're
looking at issues like cutting off parts
of the animal because it moved and just
uncomfortable positions that the cat was
in
from the beginning of my career in that
geo it was like don't cut off part of
the animal now sometimes it's very
difficult when you have a big cat with a
long tail but it makes you think in new
compositional ways
all right let's see here classic example
part of his tail is cut off
here again it's just cutting off part of
the animal same situation cutting off
parts of the animal it's gone and one of
the things that you would use is the
rule of thirds is so easy because you
can cut a horizontal frame into thirds
and then a vertical one with two lines
so it makes points in the frame
where you could put your subject
this is purely because this toy is in
the way of its face hand coming in with
the toy the toy the person they're in it
the feathers in it the feather feathers
in it feather the feathers in it and
there's nothing to catch your eyes you
have to see the eyes this is all about
emotion all art is about emotion and so
right away you're identifying with that
animal by looking right in its eye if
the face the eye you're looking at isn't
in focus so you don't have that same
connection i don't like motion blur
where you don't have part of the animal
that is sharp
and the eye is so incredibly important
in most of these images so as long as
the eyes sharp then it works the angle
of its eyes the tilt of its heads down a
little bit it looks like it's looking at
a mouse that's getting ready to kill and
i don't like the look on its face it's
kind of evil
it may work for a hallmark card about
being bummed out or something but it
doesn't work here
this is a tough one to take down but you
have to make tough choices we have to
get to that point in our whittle down
session here so it's not good enough
that concludes edit two
we have a lot more to do and most of
them have come
from the second half of the shoot
composition is so
very important and i was taught that at
a very young age as soon as an image
feels clunky you're gonna know it you
just have this clunky composition that
works for part of you as your eye moves
through the frame and then it stops you
can crop it i started with film where
there really was no cropping i try to
compose within the frame of the camera
and i think if you do that
you'll become a better photographer so
let's see what does not work one thing
you need to look for is how tight you
are on your subject do you have enough
to the city to tell the story that you'd
like to tell some of these buildings are
architecturally very interesting we need
to see that the up and down the graphic
effect and you can see the air duct here
which adds nothing and so you're
learning that as you're shooting and
just go i don't really like that i'm
gonna back up a little bit and so that
helped me here the same situation not
good enough not good you've got a better
one they're two very similar images i'm
trying to place the cat in kind of a
negative space here but you have these
modern buildings the older one here and
whether it clashes with the cat and the
angle the angle is very important in the
end because you don't really want to
look down on an animal except when i was
trying to get a compositional effect
because it takes away their power when
you're trying to tell a story about a
big city cat sitting in the window you
want to get down a little bit so you
have the same level as the window silk
because the window's not important a lot
of times when i do my remote cameras i
will have them at eye level or below and
it really changes your psychological
perspective of how you view that cat
that concludes edit three
we have 28 images left on the board
for edit four we're going to start
looking at the story of this cat
and it's home
you'll look at a complex painting
and your eye is moving around the whole
canvas and a well-composed photograph
you want your eye to move around the
canvas and in one single image to tell a
story so here we go
this one is interesting because it
actually shows some greenery outside the
window but at the end it's a very
confined image and doesn't really tell
us very much another one the same thing
just too tight on the cat
we're starting to see that we're not
getting the same feel about the story of
the cat looking out the window when it's
sitting looking into the room so those
are gone
all art is about emotion and so right
away you're identifying with that animal
by looking right in its eye or at least
being able to see it another one the
same thing some people might go wow
these are really nice and they're not
bad they show the cityscape but they're
all similar and there's not enough of
the element of the cat's home same thing
here we go one two three
four five
bye bye i wanted to get that movement
picture so here's the cat's paw up there
again just too tight on the cat and
we're not telling enough of the story
i kind of like the graphics of this in
the background in the wall and the three
wooden blocks that the cat is sitting on
but there's one i like better too
similar to another image this is a tuffy
but there's other ones that are good
that have the same kind of graphics we
have other ones that are similar so we
have to make some hard choices so i
think we're actually getting down to the
final images
[Music]
for out of five what i'm looking for is
behavior and moments that i may capture
something unexpected i think in many
instances you you may have a
preconceived notion in your mind of what
you remember and what image you think is
going to be the one that's going to be
the best but as you go through them
there'll be things that surprise you
especially if there's action involved
you may not even know that you got
something you did
graphically
it all fits you see the wooden block
just perfect with the shadow back here
and i think it works and it's the cat
that kind of reaching for something so
it's got a little bit of behavior to it
but it's not going to be the number one
or two best images from the shoots bye
bye these are really tough
i just saw one we took out that i want
to put back in
the reason i like this one in a way is
because it's like the person playing
with the cat is trying to teach it how
to be a conductor
and so there's certain elements i like
but it doesn't work the reason that i
probably like this is because i work
with big cats and seeing it walk down is
to me totally reminiscent of like a lion
or a tiger or a leopard walking down a
hill a rock or something does it tell me
a little bit more about the life of this
cat and it doesn't so it's gone
this
i like the fact and this is important
photographically and compositionally to
take a scene that you're shooting one
way and shoot it completely different
which is shoot straight down on it so
it's just something to always remember
that you do have knees you can't lay on
your stomach you can't step on a chair
or a ladder and shoot things differently
these are very graphic images that i
kind of liked as showing this cat in its
element very spare and showing shadows
in the background i kind of like this
because i like the way it was turned its
tail is coming down this way and boy you
talk about something being subjective
there'll be people it's like you picked
the wrong one keep this one and put this
one aside all right i want to say here
that i am torn between these two
pictures here and this one
i kind of like the fact that this older
architectural building is here i love
the fact that you can see the park here
i consciously after photographing the
cat with the buildings there made this
very simple it's not as complex it
doesn't tell a deep as a story but right
now photographically i like this one
better than this
now we are down to our final two images
and our final decision
[Music]
this is tough because we have two
similar views of the cat extremely
similar it's sitting there looking off
kind of aloof i really love the design
of the spare home white walls beautiful
shadow but i also am really taken by the
image of the cat with the buildings in
the background for my final decision
the image that i am going to choose
1 out of 112.
i love it it tells a story
it's ripping my heart to leave that
there but photographically this is my
favorite image
i love the graphics of it that beautiful
almost flower-like design on the wall
and the cat sitting there looking out we
don't know what it's doing where it's at
but it's a beautiful design image that
spoke to me today
so every day is the school day and as we
edit we learn what we can do next time
and that's what's very important we're
becoming more visually literate all the
time shoot and learn from the
photographs that you like and the ones
that you dislike because tomorrow you'll
be a better photographer